[Musique]
toutes mes raturé toutes les impostures
mes excès de folie qui abîment eu mes
nuits regards sur moi vous qui me jugent
évident qu'il me connaissait pas même si
vous dites que oui où êtes vous quand
j'en pleure toutes les nuits quand je
crie en silence quand je lis dans le
vide que mon frigo est vite fait mine de
rien voir avez vous peur du noir
ne me jugez pas
c'est trop facile quand on ne sait pas
c'est trop facile quand on voit pas
ne jugez pas
ah non moi je ne sais pas
c'est trop facile quand on ne sait pas
c'est trop facile quand on voit pas
ne me jugez pas
maisé kla de rire mes blagues continue
à nîmes vous font vivre ce que vous êtes
tordu mettez vous à ma place un moment
et voyez ce que j'endure souvent
je ne veux plus faire semblant d'être
heureuse devant vous que ça vous plaise
ou non bah tant pis je m'en fous
vous-même ray comme je suis ou peut-être
pas du tout je m'en fous
ne me jugez pas
[Musique]
c'est trop facile quand on sait boire
c'est trop facile quand on voit pas
ne me jugez pas
je ne sais pas
c'est trop facile quand on ne sait pas
c'est trop facile quand on voit pas
ne jugez pas
non
c'est trop facile quand on voit pas
c'est trop facile
quand on voit rien
de monsieur pas
[Musique]
c'est nous qui avons les larmes aux yeux
maintenant
chacun son tour